So we've talked about EQS as a way to perceive things in the world, to ask
queries about what's going on in the environment around us. Another way,
another important kind of very commonly used way to have AI be aware of the
world around them is through perception. So the unreal perception
system primarily functions around the perception component which is a
component that doesn't automatically come with the AI controller
but you can add to it. And it's set up to register around particular
senses. So the most commonly used ones probably being sight and hearing.
We also have touch, damage, team. There is prediction as well but that's
less commonly used. And each of these senses requires the
perception component. It is through the perception component that these
things are kind of managed and registered into the perception system.
And it's the perception component that sends the perceived actors to the AI
controller. So there's that kind of relatively tight relationship between
those two things. Obviously all of these settings can be
customized on an AI basis. You can do it per component. And all of this
stuff is also tweakable at runtime so you're not kind of baked into any
decisions you make within the editor. You can actually change all these
things on the fly. So as I said this is kind of like mainly managed through the
perception component. It can be added to the AI controller. It doesn't automatically
come with it. And it's through the AI perception component that we register
the various senses that we want this AI to utilize, to pay attention to. And
each of these senses can be manually configured and can be enabled and
disabled at will. So just because you have a hearing or a sight perception, a
sight sense, doesn't mean that you always have to be making use of it.
There's also the concept of the dominant sense being set. It's actually a
little bit difficult to find out what the dominant sense actually means.
But essentially, this is a slightly more complicated concept, but when you might
have multiple senses detecting the same target, or when you are trying to
establish where your last sense location for a particular entity was, if that
entity has been perceived by multiple systems, for example your player has made
a sound and your player has been seen recently, and you want to kind of
get your perceptions idea of where that entity is, the dominant sense
becomes quite relevant here because it's the dominant sense that will be
deferred to automatically. So if your hearing thinks the player is in
position A and your sight lasts on them in position B, and your sight is your
dominant sense, it's the sight's last perceived location that will be the
most relevant. And also a lot of this functionality is exposed to
Blueprint and a set of events which are very useful to us. We
have onPerception updated for when we've perceived different actors,
perception forgotten and target perception updated for when
individual entities are being added and lost, and perception info updated when
information about a particular target has been changed. So just
quickly talking through each of the senses, we've got a couple of different
options in front of us. This is what would be available to us if you
configured each of these senses. I'll just quickly demonstrate this in the
editor as well actually. So if I would just quickly jump into our AI
controller, you can see I've got my AI perception component that I've added
myself here, and you have a senses config which is basically which of the
senses you want this to be configured for. And here is where
you would specify your dominant sense. Obviously your dominant
sense needs to be one of the senses you have configured. If you have your
dominant senses sight and you don't have a sight config, that's kind of a
nonsense logic. So within each of these configs then you can
define settings about that. So we'll just kind of go through that on the
presentation. So first off we have sight. So these settings, most of them are
relatively obvious. Sight radius, how far you can actually visually perceive,
the distance at which once you've perceived an entity, the distance at
which you would stop perceiving it. So that can be slightly further. Peripheral
vision angle, so this is essentially what is your cone.
Detection by affiliation is where we come back to this idea of this
generic team interface. If you remember all the way back when we're talking about
the AI controller, it implements this team interface. You can essentially say do
I want to detect either friends, neutrals, or enemies, or any combination
of those things. So if I just actually quickly go to the code and expand that
wherever my sight config is, you can see we've got an option here for
detecting enemies, neutrals, and friendlies. Now if by default the kind
of standard setup when you introduce sight for the first time is that it
detects only enemies. This is one of the kind of primary reasons why it
might seem like your sight config isn't detecting anything visually. It is
probably because you haven't done a setup for the entity to be considered
an enemy. They probably don't have a team interface on it so your AI is not
perceiving it as an enemy. So the quickest way to address that is make sure
that you're just also detecting neutrals because that is the the standard setup
is just that if that thing doesn't have a team it's just going to assume
it's neutral. So the quickest way to address that and the likely issue if
you don't seem to be seeing things that you think you should be is
because you haven't got this detection by affiliation setup for
neutrals. So just returning back to our... if I don't want to open my
password manager. Just returning back to the presentation, detection by
affiliation, auto success range from last seen location, point view
backwards offset, most of these things are kind of relatively self-explanatory.
The point of view backwards offset is essentially when we're talking about to
handle the kind of concept of peripheral vision essentially.
Obviously the term peripheral vision half angle degrees is used above but
that's actually just the angle of our sight to actually handle peripheral
vision. This idea that you can kind of see things slightly outside of
your actual cone of vision because you have your your actual
perception, you have this kind of at the edge of your vision idea. The way
that it's unreal addresses that in a kind of cheap way is you have this
ability to kind of offset your cone backwards. So this would be if you
imagine the cone going from the actors eyes this offset is basically to
push that cone so the starting point can actually be behind the head.
Obviously that what that can lead to is a situation where technically you could
be seeing things that are actually behind you and so that's where near
clipping radius comes in to basically offset that to say you could
set your backwards offset by I don't know two meters and then you could also
have your near clipping radius offset by you know another two meters or half
meter and you would essentially then say there's a kind of circle around the
first meter whatever you specify where things won't be perceived to kind of
give you a not exactly a perfect cone shape but more like a rounded off edge
at the tip of the cone which would be kind of the starting point of your
of your sight. Debug color is just when we're debugging this
perception which we'll talk about a little bit at the end and then the
maximum age for a sense before we kind of stop considering that we've
perceived this thing so how old how long ago did we last have to
perceive something before we no longer kind of keep that perception values of
zero just means this this thing will never be forgotten and then starts
enabled previously self-explanatory does this sense start on. The other more
substantial perception is hearing so again substantial in comparison to the
others but still relatively small hearing range pretty self-explanatory just the
range at which we would perceive sounds when they kind of registered
anything further away than that distance that's obviously a radius
wouldn't be perceived. LOS hearing range is just a deprecated value so we
can kind of ignore that detection by affiliation we've kind of already
discussed that so when the origin of these sounds are they you know an
enemy neutral or a friend and you know we shouldn't consider things that are
either you know depending on us what our settings are we would discard sounds
from possibly friendly or neutral sources. Debug color again we'll come
back to max age the same thing and starts enabled again pretty
self-explanatory and then the next three kind of even smaller setups so
AI sense damage really the only kind of relevant setting here is the max age
and then just whether or not it would start enabled or pretty much explains
what it does. Damage the same thing we can detect by affiliation which we
can't do with touch and the max age and then the team component so
essentially where sight pretty self-explanatory hearing you're gonna
register for sounds. Touch again relatively self-explanatory it's when
you register touch sensations damage that that's probably makes a bit of
sense right like when it when damage is registered to the entity team might be
a little bit more confusing but it essentially gives our agent the ability
to react to members of the same team so this can be useful for things
like you know an agent trying to be conscious of its teammates to know when
it needs to gather up to do some kind of group attack or maybe when you have
some kind of like aggro where when you you know aggro a nearby enemy it alerts
other nearby team members that that's the way what you might need to use
team perception. The other thing kind of the other aspect of this is the AI
stimulus source component which basically gives actors a way to register
themselves as a stimuli source this is a component that can be added via
blueprint or native and it exposes which sense the actor wants to be
registered for. One kind of like interesting caveat about this is that
it's called the AI stimulus source component but actually if you look at
the C++ implementation realistically this component only exists for the AI
sense for the AI sight sense so it's a it's a useful component when you want
non-pawns to be perceived via sight but it basically has no implementation for
any of the other senses and so really this should not expose the the sense
that you want to register for and it should be called the actor sight source
component because that is really what it is useful for you can actually go to
the C++ and if you go to the AI sight dot header or a I said site sorry and
you go what is it called add source register source that's it it's this
function that is basically being used by the by the component and you'll
actually see that you know it has an implementation in AI sense site but if
we go to any of the other sense setups so if I go to AI sense hearing
register source it doesn't have an implementation so essentially it's not
and the same is true for all the other senses it is only sight and again pawns
are automatically registered for for sight perception anyway so it's worth
knowing about this similar source component but really it's only a
component you need to use for non-pawn actors when you want them to be seen
and they kind of unfortunately the rest of the senses are currently
unimplemented that has been the case for quite a long time so I it's
doubtful that the other things will receive any additional implementations
it's also not really required for the way that you actually utilize them
which I'll demonstrate in a little bit but it's just kind of an interesting
caveat that's worth bearing in mind it doesn't that doesn't really get said
everywhere but the AI stimulus source component is really only useful for
sight and only useful things aren't already pawns because those things will
be automatically registered for the first sight stimulus anyway so before I
kind of move on to the the last the kind of last slide of this section
which is talking a little bit about debugging I figure one of the things
that I should actually show is how we would actually register these these
different senses so we've got these these senses set up we can say you
know we've got a hearing set up we can say we've got a touch but it's it's
a kind of natural conclusion that if you have sight all it requires is for
your actor to have some kind of geometry that can be observed and you
know for the most part that is actually true as long as it is either
an actor and it has the AI stimulus at the site stimulus or it is a pawn then
it will it will just get seen right so this is an actor I have and this actor
is implemented while the AI the controller it's using has the
perception component with all those things set up so if I can and if you
actually look at the controller so this is the controller that actor is
using you can see I've we've got the on perceived on perception updated where
basically just printing out new things that have been perceived right
for 10 seconds so this is basically just to show you that when we perceive
something we print it so if I were to turn this actor to face this thing and
play it's seen my it's seen my player straight away I guess my cone is too
big so I'll just turn it slightly this way and you'll see it's perceiving
this empty pawn over here so we don't require the geometry it just needs it's
a pawn you can already see that automatically this point doesn't have
any stimulus component on it it's just a pawn it's got nothing on it but it's
getting perceived but if I wanted it but it's not seeing this cube and I
wanted to see this cube so then we just need to add that stimulus
component stimulus source and even though this is kind of only useful for site
we do still need to register it for that sense so also register the
source you can also just call a function to do this but we might as
well auto register it and we'll register it as a source for site and
now when I play that you'll see it detects the cube you can see it's
seeing the pawn and it's seeing the cube so that is how we have non pawn
actors get perceived by site so that's that's for site that just works again
because my player is obviously characters inherit from pawns you can
see it will automatically see that the player and then goes on often does
other logic which we'll talk a little bit more about in a bit but for the
other senses it's not so obvious one might assume that for the hearing for
the hearing perception all you need to do is play a sound in a location near
the entity but that doesn't work they won't do anything and similarly for
touch maybe you'd think that you just need to have some kind of collision
with the with the collision of the entity again that won't work for
damage you might think that you just need to use unreal's apply damage
function and it will perceive that damage but it will not no so you're
kind of natural senses about all of these things are unfortunately quite
likely wrong if that was your natural sense actually each of these different
AI each of these senses have their own kind of report event to kind of
notify that that particular sense so in the case of noise we have report
noise event and you can you've given a couple of different settings
available so you know where has this noise been created what's the loudness
loudness essentially just acts as pretty much a multiplier on your max range so
obviously this would work in conjunction with your perceived range
so if your perceived range were high but the max range were not high enough
then that wouldn't necessarily be perceived and you can provide it a tag
which is just useful for other parts of the perception system so this is kind
of just additional information about this noise and then obviously who
actually created the noise so we can see that that's how where we're doing a
sound you can see we're not importantly we're not playing any
sounds here we're just reporting a noise event so if I press 1 you can
see in fact I will turn off the remove the stimulus component from my
cube so that it can't be perceived anymore we can see it's no longer
displaying the cube but you can see that when I go to report the noise it is
printing cube and that's because the cube has come up has been detected
via the sound because it is the instigator of that sound so that's
that's where our kind of noise event comes in for the others I've just done
a little setup here so you can see we in this kind of example setup I am
applying damage this is just a normal unreal function this is kind of like
unreal's built-in way for actors to damage other actors but again this in
itself doesn't actually do anything with the with the damage sense it's not
going to not going to do anything the important part of this is if we go to
the example AI char which is the AI enemy char what I've done is on
receiving damage so this is just an event that you can bind to there's two
event damage you can do event any damage point damage radial damage so
I've just done any damage that's coming in report that damage as an
event so if this if I apply this damage it will perceive the the source
of that damage sorry jumping all over the place here it will perceive the
source of that damage at a location and just to kind of show that off again
which one is it's button two you can see it's by doing that it's
detecting the thing that is causing the damage
it's detecting our player character but the only reason it's doing that is
because we're reporting it through this event so if I were to unhook that
reporting event even though we are technically damaging the enemy it's
not doing anything so so that essentially and that's for the damage
system so if I'll just hook that back up and then lastly we have touch
again one might expect that it just requires a collision it doesn't it
requires its own event which is touch so typically a small setup I've done here
is just if something hits the collision of this thing
if the thing that did the hitting was the example player character then
report that touch event so this is very very gameplay driven
so now if I bump into it one second make sure that's actually
firing off there might be something ongoing here why haven't set
something up to trigger hit events
yes no but you can see it is reporting that touch event
so that is that's essentially the kind of various ways that we can
notify each of these senses that that's happening so for
for our hearing touch and damage we have these reporting events
and for sight we have the these well all we need to do is physically
be in space and be a pawn or we can physically be in space and just have
that the stimulus component
and then the last thing to be aware of is whenever we're talking about any
of the AI systems it's good to be aware of the kind
of debugging functionality so we already talked a little bit about the kind of
nav mesh we can press p and toggle this on and off but the
other thing that we can do is actually debug our AI states
now kind of the inverse of our debugging nav this only works whilst you're in
play but it basically gives you the ability
to kind of live report on lots of AI stuff that's going on so
this isn't purely for perception although perception is a component in it
if you press the apostrophe key which you know on my english keyboard is on
the same symbol as at but may your keyboards may
differ but if you press the apostrophe key
wherever that is you'll see you get this kind of like
a lot of information appearing on screen and you can essentially if you
look along the top here you can press different numbers to
i think those are actually num keys so let me do that again you can press
different number i don't have num pad on yeah now i've
got num lock on you can turn on and off
debugging about different systems so i can turn on eqs i can turn on
perception smart objects which we'll talk about
in a little bit AI in general information about the behavior tree
just it's worth knowing that this debugging functionality is available
and it's within this perception component it's within this debugging
system that those perception colors become relevant that
we were kind of just looking at all the sense configs for their
different color setups so just be worth bearing in mind that this exists
so just that we're kind of at the end of the section where we're talking
about the kind of fundamental bits of the AI system the rest is
we're going to go into talking a little bit about plugins but just as a little
bit of a reflection i thought what we would do
is go through a little bit of a setup that i've got here
but also quickly dig through an example
of a behavior tree from one of epic's own games so they have
since 5.0 this this project isn't necessarily so relevant but it's still
kind of interesting to to dig away at the kind of more contemporary example of
this is the lyra project it's essentially a very substantial
kind of best practice viable project that you can download in unreal
uh for a whole bunch of things they do lots of cool things with geometry
script with ai with ui and so it's it's worth looking at for
a whole host of reasons but the kind of project that prefaced
lyra that kind of occupied a similar space was just called shooter game
you can still download it for any version of unreal up to 427
which is the kind of last version of unreal 4 but it's not really an unreal
5 project you probably can convert it but just for the sake of being able to
look at it what i've done is i've taken one of the behavior trees
from that project and i've pulled it forward into ue5
and i've also pulled over the relevant c++ classes
so if you download this project and you go to 11503 which is the
ai course you'll see there's this shooter game code folder if you're
wondering what that's about that is just the relevant bits of the
um from the the shooter game uh that are
kind of relevant to the behavior tree so i just pulled over the kind of
minimum c++ stuff so that we didn't have
empty missing nodes and you'll see in occasional places i've actually commented
out bits of code that just kind of not relevant or are referencing actors
that i haven't pulled over just to kind of reduce the amount of
bloat i'm pulling over um but just to kind of quickly look at
this because i think it's kind of an interesting frame of reference for us
what a slightly more substantial behavior tree might look like
um if i go to shooter game ai and then bot behavior
like this still isn't like the biggest behavior tree that you've ever
seen but you can see a kind of good example for how we
might use all of these things so again using what we already know we
our root goes straight into a composite node which is a selector which the
only thing it's legally allowed to do and our selector which again is
essentially here to choose a single behavior
is going to prioritize this branch of the tree first then if that
fails then it's going to move to this and last of all is going to
defer in the end to this okay so and then as soon as we're in
this branch of the tree so which
essentially all the time we have these two services running so
what are these two services doing we have a
one service which is searching for an enemy at los i actually haven't looked
at the the code for this but one can infer
from the name that it's probably using some kind of line tracing
to possibly find you know an enemy and
assign that that value and then it's got a service to
basically be shooting an enemy so this is the idea of like
we already spoke about the fact that in some ways services
can replace parallel behavior because really this is just running
all the time it's doing other things just whilst you're running around
doesn't mean that doesn't that doesn't stop you from looking at and shooting
an enemy so this is a kind of a way that you
could utilize that kind of parallel nature of services to be doing one
thing whilst also doing other things and you know you don't have to choose
between the two so we've got the selector with these two services on it
the first priority is what seems to be about
basically going to get ammo so as you can see the the first thing we've got
here is a decorator that's saying do we even
need ammo and you can see the query is whether
or not the blackboard key needs ammo is set and that you can see
that it aborts any lower priorities so this is to imply that if we were in
one of these lower branches you know either of these branches and
then suddenly we needed ammo they would abort out and we would
start this one instead um and yeah i think i think that's pretty
self-explanatory we can actually go and look at the blackboard quickly and
see what needs ammo is it's a bull that's not super surprising um
so if essentially if this is um set um then we can actually
um go and do something about that so our first function
is a task here called find a pickup which i believe
is yeah this is one of the c++ tasks so you can kind of look at that
again a lot of this stuff is actually commented out just to reduce the amount
that we're pulling over but you can kind of look through the
c++ if you're interested like how that might look
um so that's a c++ implementation of a task
and then um first we go to find the pickup and because this is a sequence we
kind of want both of these things to succeed
so we would find the pickup and then we would do one of these two things
um so we're going to do this which is pick up the ammo
and if that fails then we're going to do this which looks like a
a task that essentially i think just returns true to kind of exit out of the
exit out of the tree i suspect um and then obviously we can see that
uh by i presume this means that if this returns
true then it's going to come up here if this gets to here so this this
didn't return true it failed they just want it to return true
anyway so i suspect if we wait inside this return true hack
it's probably which is a blueprint task uh yeah we can see it just it receives
the execute and all it does is instantly
finish with success um so it is kind of doing what it says on the tin
really um so either way no matter what we do
here um as long as find a pickup doesn't fail
that would lead to this failing um as long as that doesn't fail
then um even if this either one of these will succeed and then the selector will
succeed meaning this sequencer will succeed
and we'll go back up to here it doesn't matter ultimately anyway
because at that point it's coming back up to this selector and then
either way it's going to do the next thing so it would return up to the
route and then come back down again and it's ascertain
whether or not we still need ammo if we do still need ammo then it
would return here otherwise we go to here
to our second branch um where we've got some more decorators so
we check whether or not we've got an enemy again this will abort
our our kind of like fallback behavior which is just
doing nothing for four seconds so if we suddenly get an enemy
uh whilst we're idling we'll abort that and kind of re-execute this tree
um and this will uh this is limiting us to
only be able to perform this a certain number of times before it
automatically will fail um and then similarly we've got this
selector behavior so again reminder that a selector is just
wanting to do one of these behaviors so it's it's
looking for the first one that succeeds
so we're going to go down to here our first kind of highest priority thing
is our attack sequence finding a point near our enemy
and we can see you know again we had to have an enemy to even be into this
branch so we we can assume that this uh would find a
point near whatever that blackboard key is move to that enemy
and then basically attack the enemy and you can see this has got a time limit
decorator on it which will essentially say that this
will only execute for a certain amount of time before failing out
um or um uh yes or or it finishes
um and then regardless of what we do there then
um even if we even if attack enemy kind of finishes naturally itself
all we do next is return true anyway so at that point we're
coming back out here if this succeeded then the selector will return
succeed if it failed it will just move on
um to waiting for five seconds at which point it will just return true
anyway so a slightly more complex setup than
the behavior tree that we looked at but it's just interesting to see how
how someone else does it and the kind of different the cool different
things that we're using here so you know the fact that um shooting as an
enemy can be a service it's might not that might not be a
logical thing to necessarily do all the time um
the idea that we've kind of you know our highest priority thing is actually
finding ammo which in the context of a shooting game
probably actually makes sense because you can't really do much else if you
don't have ammo so some of these things uh you know
they make sense once you've been in it for a while but they might seem a
little bit um non-intuitive initially um so
that's just an implementation i thought was kind of interesting to diagnose
um and then yeah i've just got a little bit of a setup to kind of
demonstrate some of these different behaviors that we've talked about
i'll just return to the behavior tree that um
i showed off before to kind of show exactly what we're doing here
um again so we're kind of like over diagnosis of
behavior trees maybe but uh kind of a little bit of a simpler setup
essentially uh we have this um check for whether or not we have a target if
we do have a target we find the location near that target we
already looked at what this eqs does so it finds a point around that target
closest to us move to it and then do attack the player
um and then if we don't have a target then we do this
where we do this this eqs does nothing it was simply to kind of like
put it there to demonstrate what a service would look like we
find a location a random location in the radius
we wait for five seconds and then we move to that location
so the only thing that i kind of feel like is worth showing off quickly
here is actually what a um a manually scripted
task looks like um so we've got the when are you when
you actually go to make a a task yourself you can obviously do
that in c++ or you can do it in blueprint
if you were to do it from blueprint you would go
like this blueprint class and you can just do btt
and btt task blueprint base similarly there is btd for
decorator blueprint base and bts for service base so you can make
blueprints of any of the services tasks or decorators
and you'll note as well that you can only make
these things inheriting from blueprint base if you try and go further up the
tree you don't have an option here and then if you were to make a task
um then that basically looks like this
you're just given a suite of override functions
and this is essentially how you implement the behavior of that task so
the kind of key thing being receive execute which is basically start
doing this task and the way a task works in in behavior trees is they just
run until you call this function finish execute
so as i said every kind of node in um well certainly tasks um
have the ability to kind of return three states where they can be
um you know success success failure or waiting kind of like uh
they're ongoing um and so that the with a with a task
when you receive execute essentially you are
it's going to be in that kind of pending ongoing mode
until you call finish execute that could be you know
within the same frame that could be um after a few seconds it could be
infinite um it kind of just depends on whatever your requirements are
so just to briefly look at this btt attack
all i do is get the the person who's executing this which in
in our case is the you know the ai this is our pawn
um and we check whether or not they've got this attacker interface
now this is just a blueprint interface that i made
um and this is just a kind of a way to kind of kick the can down the road
to a degree in that um this this interface
exists and it has some functions in it which is you know
attack either a target actor or attack a target location if you could imagine
that you know if you had um a heat seeking missile
maybe you would this would use the target and if you
had something like a mortar you maybe you would attack the location or
something like that but um this actually does nothing so if
i were to go to our um actual enemy
i have implemented the attacker interface but if we actually
go to that these these uh there's no
implementation for these functions this is just to kind of demonstrate how
one might do it um but yeah so we would say we launch
the attack at this either this particular actor we
launch the attack at this target and then we just finish now a kind of
more comprehensive setup might be like a start launching attack and then you
wait for the attack to let you know that
it's finished and that's when you finish executing the task
but this is kind of more a fire and forget setup that's
very much a kind of a design decision that you would need to make internally
but this is just roughly how i've set it up i check for the
interface if we don't have the interface we just execute fail
we finish execute and we fail if we do have the interface then we just check
whether the we can pass in a blackboard key
we check what kind of blackboard key that is if it's an object
then we do the attack target actor if it's not an object if it's a
vector then we do attack location if it's neither of those things then we
fail because we were only really meant to be taking in
vector keys or object keys and then all we do is again call
attack target actor or attack location and then just finish execute success
so you know relatively limited implementation but just to kind of
demonstrate how one might implement a task
obviously there's a bunch of pre-existing examples in in the code
base you can look for how those are as well as those
ones that i've pulled in from the from the
shooter game example and then the other thing is just this
btt find random location in radius where you can kind of see pretty simple
it takes in a blackboard key this is the value that we're going to update
and we essentially just pick a random value in a kind of box
area we can we can choose a radius and we just kind of do that and we just
generate a random number and that's all it does
so we could also do this through an eqs but this is just something that i i
thought this was kind of a simpler implementation and
kind of again demonstrated another way that we can do
implement a task and that's pretty much all we've got
there so we've seen the setup here essentially
walk around in random points unless we have a target at the point that we have
the target run an eqs query to find the closest
point around that target to us move to it and then attack the player
attacking a player does nothing but it you know it will
we can imagine what that might do in a proper implementation
so the other things to be aware of is that this ai
has again we've already seen the ai controller it's got all these
different senses set up we print when we perceive things
so if i um it's complaining about some errors in
the uh in the shooter game code but you can see it perceives me and
then it does the eqs query and it kind of moves up to me and you
can just assume that it's attacking me and we can see all of that stuff
happening live we just open the behavior tree
um we can see that kind of repeatedly happening
obviously at no point are we clearing the target so it's kind of just stuck
in this forever um but again if we were just to stop
and play again uh we can just watch that happen
taking over so it's sitting around in the idle behavior
um it's just finding locations moving to them just snap this to the side of
my screen you can see it doing that behavior
and if it were to kind of happen to turn around
and see me then it's instantly into attack mode and it's kind of like
forever in that attack loop and again the way that we're assigning
this this target actor if we actually go to our ai controller
is just when we perceive something um if we've got some perceived actors we're
going to loop through that array we'll print it just for the sake of
debugging um and then we just cast to we see if
the perceived actor is a pawn if it's a pawn
this is just a quick way to check whether or not it's the it's the
player character this way you don't have to cast to a particular type of
um character you can just say is it a pawn and is it a player controlled
pawn that's the easiest way to say is this the player pawn and if it is
then we set that blackboard value and then that
will trigger this uh this blackboard based condition which will abort the
lower tree if we're in it and go into this attack behavior so we
can see all of that logic working this is kind of like the small
implementation of a behavior tree and how
how we could stitch these things together so as i said that's the kind
of last part of the kind of fundamentals
of the um of the system and now what we're moving on to is just a kind of
couple of um plugins just to be aware of that
could be useful if you're doing ai behavior not all of
them only apply to ai but they do have some kind of
overlap with those things